this is all very good timing right now
because there seems to be certainly a
lot more awareness right of the gender
pay gap and that women need to have more
equality and you hear that also in the
county campaign trail uh what did you
make just being that you are now you
know you're in this industry what did
you make of Jennifer Lawrence's coming I
was so thrilled that she you know she's
a huge star she's the highest-paid
female actress and you know its Katniss
come alive basically you know inspire
the rest of us to you know demand gender
equality and you know it's not just
among actors but among directors you
know which is why game-changer was
formed only seven percent of the top 250
grossing films last year were directed
by women seven percent that's a terrible
number you know it's worse than
aerospace engineers and clergy right and
there aren't only seven percent
directors out there female direct no
there aren't one independent world is
eighteen percent in the studio world at
seven percent so you know as you get
higher and higher in the in the wrongs
that women just sort of whittled down
unfortunately well I mean look we have a
quote here from Lawrence from that from
that sa she wrote it i believe i'm lena
Dunham's newsletter where she said quote
I got mad at myself I failed as a
negotiator because I gave up early so
what are you finding yourself as you're
in Hollywood and as you're trying to
finance these films i mean do you find
that there really is a bias there
definitely is i mean financing is
largely controlled by men and i think
that you know men are more comfortable
financing people who walk and talk like
them you know and i think that is
probably the number one reason why there
are so few women directors is that the
lack of access to financing all right
which is why game ginger was formed so
who are you getting financing from we're
getting financing from a great group of
social impact investors who care not
only about the you know seeing women
gender equality in the film world but
also are passionate about the arts and
film so don't you think though that that
with more platforms like Hulu and
Netflix and Amazon I mean isn't that
isn't that leveling the game a little
bit aren't thing we're open they are
more open and however you know a lot of
them are being a lot of the ranks of the
staff are being populated by old TV
executives in studio executives i think
i think they are becoming more
traditional but you know what those
companies have done is open up the
sort of content formats right so there's
been the rise of the limited series for
example miniseries and I think this are
there are more opportunities in episodic
now than there were well there are not I
find that you know the women who the
actors who are getting more notice that
they may have not got it knows before
are more women and that they're giving
more chances to like let's say Jane
Fonda who of course is I ganic but you
know she haven't been in a really big
movie in a long time and now she's on
this on this netflix netflix series
absolutely I'm just quickly with some
numbers of hard numbers here Robert
Downey jr. guys let's pull this up he's
the highest-paid actor I didn't know
that actually I thought it was Charlie
Sheen 80 million dollars Jennifer
Lawrence at 52 million dollars and if
you want to talk about Hollywood pay gap
it's right there right yeah absolutely
you know and it's it's interesting as
women are undervalued not just you know
on screen off screen we're under valued
as audiences you know and you know more
than fifty percent of ticket sales are
attributed to women yeah yeah so I feel
like there's this whole marketplace
opportunity that's untapped and women
filmmakers are an undervalued asset
which is why game changer was formed all
right great minute thank you so much for
joining us minute Louie the president of
game changer film